Can you explain why soy is good or bad for breast cancer? So soy and soy isol flavonoids,
label them, label them are estrogenic. That's why they're bad. So even if it's organic,
so the only difference is if it's fermented, so for men did soy is totally different.
That's what highland is. Highland is a fermented soy supplement that acts completely different than soy.
So if it's fermented, it actually can dislodge bad estrogens from estrogen beta receptors.
If it's not, or that did that it can actually block estrogen beta receptors and estrogen beta receptors are apoptotic receptors on the cell membranes of illicit cells also has been definitely on cancer cells again blocked.
So soy is, I would say soy shouldn't be used by anybody period whether you have cancer or not.
So soy is not a good thing to be eating that if I the vast majority of soy grown in the United States,
and it could be purchased that it states is all GMO. So it's another reason why not to be using soy.
But even organic non GMO soy is going to be estrogenic and you we do not need anymore zero estrogens in our body.
You know, we're having all sorts of estrogenic issues because of that so that should be a no no to everybody male or female whether you have cancer or not should not be consuming a lot of soy.